remember a couple weeks ago when acting
Attorney General Matthew Whitaker
testified before the House Judiciary
Committee he must have said a thousand
times that he has had no conversations
with Donald Trump about any
investigations relating to Donald Trump
in any way it was hard to believe it
when he said it but Whitaker was under
oath he was repeating the exact same
claim here's just one example of where
Whitaker denied having such
conversations with Trump you
communicated anything you learned in
that briefing to put about the
investigation to President Trump
yes or no mr. chairman as I've said
earlier today in my opening remarks I do
not intend today to talk about my
private conversations with the president
United States but to answer your
question I have not adopted the
president United States about the
special counsels investigation this is
one of dozens of examples I've not
talked to Trump about this investigation
I've not talked to Trump about any
investigations relating to him yesterday
the New York Times broke a story which
claims that Donald Trump not only spoke
to Matthew Whitaker about investigations
into him he specifically pressured
Whitaker to do multiple things number
one Trump reportedly pressured Matthew
Whitaker to take control of an
investigation into hush money payments
to women this would be obstruction of
justice by Donald Trump Whitaker
reportedly went to colleagues and made
the vague assertion that the Southern
District of New York needs quote adult
supervision sdn why of course was the
investigator in that case that would be
an example of Whitaker interfering in an
investigation at the direction of the
president that's a crime but most
importantly think back to that clip I
just played for you Matthew Whitaker
denied having such conversations
multiple times during his recent
hearings before the House Committee
this means that Whitaker lied he
testified and said I haven't talked to
Trump I haven't talked to Trump about
any investigations if the New York Times
allegations are true that was a lie and
it is another crime the crime of perjury
and even when you look at the details
they are nutty during a call about this
investigation which whitaker remembered
denied took place but now we believe
actually did happen Donald Trump asked
Whittaker to put a man named Jeffrey
Berman in charge of that investigation
into Trump Berman happens to be a trump
ally in the SDN why and as a result
Berman recused himself from the
investigation because he's tied to Trump
like Jeff Sessions he shouldn't be
involved in these investigations didn't
matter Trump specifically requested to
Matthew Whitaker that he put Berman in
charge everyone on the Trump side is
just denying this they're denying
everything but the answers here are very
very plain and simple Whitaker publicly
said before becoming acting attorney
general he's hostile to the Moller probe
he believes the Moller probe is an
overreach he has specific ideas in his
head about how he would interfere with
the Moller probe he said all of that
before he became Attorney General Trump
then appoints him to be Attorney General
every normal person says it's obvious
why he's doing it he's doing it so that
Whitaker will get involved and interfere
Whittaker comes in and does exactly the
stuff that he publicly said he would
like to do and now we're supposed to
believe the Trump team's denials despite
the fact that it seems every single
person involved in this fiasco is lying
if it looks like a duck and it smells
like a duck and it acts like a duck the
Trump team says it's an airplane
but it's a duck that's the reality and
this explains everything it explains the
flopsweat constantly on Whitaker's
forehead every single time he was asked
about this stuff it explains the bizarre
language and demeanor that Matthew
Whitaker exhibited when he was
testifying about this this is as bad as
the worst scenario that we could have
imagined and the most disturbing part of
this that I just am increasingly
disgusted with is that there may be no
consequences there may not be
consequences to any of this so all we
can do is make sure that we remove this
man from office in
2020 and not not a day later let me know
what you think about this new allegation
from the New York Times I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show one of today's
sponsors is privacy dot-com slash Pakman
this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below